morning guys how are we why am I here to
build a kitchen and to get a production
going and give you guys a chance to earn
and learn and put back inside
these are crafted it is popular Grafton
yeah its proper graft listen let's be
honest you get out of it we put into it
good question ready 20 years ago I got
dealt a dysfunctional cars
my little brother became a heroin addict
and my father became an alcoholic what
do I do
I sit there and join my little brother
or I become an alcoholic alongside my
father no I got my ass I stopped for
feeling sorry for myself and I got on
with it put my head down learn the craft
and that's the journey I'm hoping that
we're gonna go on thank you I think he
played it well because he's he's told us
a bit about himself he's history how he
how he became a cook and you know he's
told us about his family I have less
than six months to kick this motley crew
into shape and try and mold them into a
kitchen outfit that can pay its way but
can any of them even cook a simple dish
of scrambled eggs Passport any talent
here
[Music]
little task no plate of scrambled eggs
please a burglar Anthony Kelly age 33 is
a career criminal having spent half his
life in and out of prison what jobs you
got before you got in cocaine ten years
[Music]
last time he makes comedy oh nice yeah
you getting romantic now
45 now last month so yeah 25 years no
you're kidding me yeah yeah
bubbles 90 minutes cooking's 125 hours
of prime no taste
[Music]
disgusted me if it is an omelette with
what every all right next up
forty-five-year-old Londoner Lawrence
Gibbons is it a spelling mistake on
their nine convictions or 79 I've got 69
could it no 669 lost your 69 no 76
convictions man know what some people
called prime we've pulled it away alive
my First's things up in post offices
booger this time it's a soul that I'm in
before whereas before I've been done for
drugs
the fascinating thing about you but
having at school together
that's 45 last month how come you look
older than me up and I must do with
money you've got your downline please
taste cooked
it's becoming apparent that I'm starting
at rock-bottom here we've got leaking
the ceiling what's water
[Music]
this law can't tell their ass from their
elbow Tesla Jones from South London has
been in trouble with the law since he
was 12 I think um no I've been several
times before I actually grew up in
prison I understand I spent most of my
teenage years in prison the opportunity
that I've got now and I mean maybe I'm
the next corner Ramsey maybe I'm the
blackboard and Ramsey that water come
out the side wasn't that means um what
does that mean
we won't quit long enough no it's
overcooked by the way I think Tesla is
willing to work hard but he's a disaster
in the kitchen
[Music]